If we put liquid nitrogen inside of a rubber balloon, will the balloon freeze and crack and spill liquid nitrogen everywhere, or will it expand and blow up?
I'm not really sure, so that's the purpose of this experiment today.
I got this little thermos filled with liquid nitrogen, and it's so well insulated, it's not even getting cold on the outside. That's pretty cool.
So, I think the best way to get the liquid nitrogen inside the balloon is to blow it up a little bit, turn it around and
put it on top of this thermos, and then we'll turn the thermos upside down, and spill some liquid nitrogen down inside it.
Alright, let's see what happens when I pour the liquid nitrogen in.
There we go. Worked out pretty well so far.
Whoops.
Okay! Cool!
It's actually blowing itself up. It looks like its gonna blow up too, doesn't it? [kid says "Yeah!" in the background]
It's getting bigger! [kid says "Yeah."] [another kid says "Uh oh!"]
You can see just how big this is getting right now, and it's getting very tight. I think it's going to explode.
[explosion of the ballon] Woo.
[kid says "Oh."] There it goes.
[replay of explosion]
Wow, look at all the little liquid nitrogen beads all over the ground.
[kid saying "Little wittle nitrogen. These aren't getting bigger."]
This ones still bubbling, that one's kind of like-- wooh!
When I touch it, it just curls up. You can see all these little pieces of shrapnel. It just competently shredded that balloon.
Okay, so honestly I didn't think that was going to work. I thought the balloon would get so cold the rubber would crack and all the liquid nitrogen would flow out.
So, to see that, that balloon would actually blow up that big is very encouraging, so I've got a really cool idea with some of those 6 foot water balloons.
Let's see if we can make those work. Oh yeah.